l'amour au-delà des préjugés Joceline
Bonsant morpasienne de 78 ans est
atteinte d'une myopathie cette maladie
génétique entraîne une diminution
progressive de l'ensemble des muscles de
son organisme à l'âge de 41 ans elle
rencontre son futur époux à son travail
à l'époque Joceline exerce en tant
qu'aide médico-psychologique à la page à
Versailles une association pour
accompagner les personnes en situation
de handicap Jean-Paul atteint d'une
sclérose en plaque fait partie des
nouveaux bénéficiaires la directrice
m'avait demandé de faire un stage de
théâtre et de l'art de dire le mot que
je suis revenue après ce
stage lui il est revenu avec des des des
des des poèmes et quand j'ai lu si to
après que j'ai fini il s'est avancé vers
moi et il me dit ah c'est comme ça que
je voulais qu'on qu' lise mais pour
merci ta ta voix m'a fait retrouver ma
foi j'étais lu un jeu chez lui dans dans
sa tête dans son cœur et puis après il y
aéclair un coup de foudre de ce passionn
d'écriture Jean-Paul aime rédiger des
lettres à son épouse des phrases mêlées
d'humour et d'amour au fil des mois
Joceline s'attache à cet homme positif
et généreux une histoire fusionnelle
malgré le handicap nous sommes humains
donc nous avons un cœur et quand on
parle d'amour c'est hisire le cœur le
cœur sans amour et l'amour sans cœur ça
va pas un être humain déjà il aé par
amour c'est l'amour d'un père et d'une
mère qui on que on est on qu'on est
évidemment c'est il nous on vous faites
le bisous de bisous le
bisous c'était de beaux
instants 3 ans après leur rencontre les
amoureux se mari dans la commune de
trappe en présence de leur famille une
relation indéfectible sous le regard
parfois critique des autres sur leur
couple ça disa que je
su j'étais un peu FO surtout quand ça
mal'adie parce que cétait c'est très
très difficile très dur des fois quand
il avait ces cris maniaac
dépressives impressionnant VO quelque
fois je me demandais mais oh là
qu'est-ce que j'ai fait comme bêtise
finalement c'est pas de bêtise puisque
bonà il il a la bour et puis c'est la
maladie suite à sa sclérose en plaque
Jean-Paul est hospitalisé en 1998 à
l'âge de 53 ans la veille de son décès
Joceline se rente à son chevet des
sourires et de tendres baisés échangés
croyante elle pè revoir son bien aimé
dans l'au delà